mein thema heute ist dass wer sich mit
dem zeitgeist verheiratet der ist bald
witwer und genau das ist das ergebnis
das wir auch am 26 september gesehen
haben
umfragen stimmungen und veröffentlichte
meinung hat eine größere rolle gespielt
als tatsächlich weitsichtigkeit und
pragmatische politik das hat eine lange
genesis ist es ging 2008 schon los mit
der griechenland-krise
2011 natürlich aufgrund eines
einzelereignis fukushima war die
stimmung so dass alle aus der atomkraft
aussteigen wollten wir kennen die
aktuelle situation darum waren die
preise explodieren wir wissen nicht wie
wir energie sicherheit gewährleisten
können in zukunft
2013 ganz interessant da ist die partei
mit den eigenen konservativen nicht sehr
gut umgegangen war alles was konservativ
bezeichnet wurde ein rechten touch
bekommen hat insofern haben wir dann
eine entwicklung gesehen die dann
ruderte in der gründung der afg 2015
flüchtlingskrise ich glaube das brauche
ich nicht weiter erläutern bisschen
jetzt tatsächlich zum umgang mit der
korona krise getrieben von stimmungen
getrieben von umfragen auch personeller
natur wir haben gerade das thema markus
söder angesprochen und die quittung kam
am 26 september der bürgerliche wähler
hat die scheidungspapiere eingereicht
was die cdu betrifft und sie wollen eben
nicht
zeitgeist politik sondern politik mit
weitblick also ich teile diese diese
analyse und meine außen diagnose die ich
damit alle vorsicht natürlich und
respekt der äußere sie haben in der
deutschen politik haben sie hat ziemlich
viele trauen tänze die da unterwegs sind
die sozialen klar und dance die grünen
trauen denn zusammen sie die
vergangenheit drei tänze da die da hat
sich in die ins mittelalter zurück
träumen und die cdu müsste ja eigentlich
die partei der wirklichkeit sei die
deutschen sind ja eigentlich pragmatiker
tüchtige leute man weiß man muss zuerst
arbeiten bevor man das geld ausgeben
kann und die cdu hat hier tatsächlich
ihren kompass verloren die haben sich zu
stark einfach als macht gewinnungs
verein verstanden frau merkel hat das
natürlich auf die spitze getrieben und
deshalb sage ich ist diese opposition
jetzt für die cdu riesige chance und ich
wünschte mir wenn ich das noch anfügen
darf ich wünschte mir dass es da richtig
kracht und laute diskussionen gibt nicht
ob eine dort in andere zu sehr
kritisiert sondern zur sache zu den
themen was ist eigentlich unsere
botschaft was ist unsere position und da
bin ich jetzt sehr gespannt ob das
gelingen wird das je wieder eine
inhaltliche besinnung stattfindet in der
opposition weil jetzt war einfach eine
macht gewinnung eine art rotary club mit
der da irgendwo in den teppichetagen der
politik abonniert ist also ich sehe es
positiv ich glaube die kommen in der
opposition wieder zurück also wenn
opposition sozusagen das der jungbrunnen
ist dann müssen die bayerische spd
inzwischen bei 8 prozent
sie hat seit 70 jahren opposition nicht
die show also insofern habe ich da meine
zweifel der opposition war wirklich sich
sich erneuern kann aber eines muss man
auch sehen merkel hat die partei geführt
nach gutsherrenart
alles hört auf mein kommando und die
partei hat sich kritik gefallen lassen
ich kann mich erinnern an den parteitag
2015 höhepunkt flüchtlingskrise in
karlsruhe dann gab es ein antrag von den
von den leuten werde union boss macht
und sollte nicht sagten etwas was ich
ganz witzig fand die bundesregierung
wird aufgefordert bei der zuwanderung
die bestehenden gesetze zu beachten dass
als regierungspartei
das würde dann die wie so üblich im
leitantrag irgendwie verwurstet und all
diese kämpfer die ihn dann am zweiten
tag als ihr antrag auf der tagesordnung
war in die bütt hingehen müssen dann
alle weg
wichtige träger wie die warenpreise oder
so das heißt die partei hat sich auch
mehr oder weniger
enden wandeln lassen und unterworfen das
merke dass mary das nutzten einige liegt
also es gibt auch andere beispiele wie
2016 hat der bundesparteitag beschlossen
kein doppelpass ja so und was daraufhin
passiert das wissen wir auch und da geht
es dann doch wieder auch um stimmungen
und umfragen die angela merkel da
genutzt hat und natürlich auch die
presse diesbezüglich zu sagen es sich
nicht um und das sind zwei punkte über
die sich die cdu jetzt wirklich klar
werden muss kann man auf diesem weg
weitermachen ja oder nein ich persönlich
glaube definitiv nicht wenn wir uns
wieder besinnen auch gegenwind ja aus
bestimmten medien stuben herausstehen
und pragmatischen politik machen auch
mit weitblick auch mal unter diesem
aspekt was sind da die entscheidende
themen aus ihrer sicht allerdings
thematik zum beispiel nach wie vor wir
haben es gesehen bei der bundestagswahl
das zwei themen uns völlig abhanden
gekommen sind ist die
wirtschaftskompetenz und die
sicherheitskompetenz und es geht ja
mittlerweile schon so weit also wenn ich
die soziale marktwirtschaft hoch halte
und sage die grundbedingungen der
sozialen marktwirtschaft ist zum
beispiel eigentum ist eigenverantwortung
dann muss ich ja heutzutage wirklich
schon vorsichtig sein nicht in die
rechte ecke geschoben zu werden und wenn
ich das nicht aushalten als politiker
und das nicht aushalte als partei dann
brauche ich mich braucht man uns
irgendwann nicht mehr da stimme ich
ihnen zu ich mich stört nur an ihrer
argumentation das wort zeitgeist die cdu
sei 'der den zeitgeist hinterher
gelaufen ich würde behaupten die cdu hat
den zeitgeist nicht mehr genug getroffen
denn die cdu ist total zeitgeist
deutschland ist total cdu deutschland
ist total konservativ deutschland ist
total märz außerhalb von berlin auf dem
land vor allen dingen im westen
deutschlands deutschland ist tief
konservativ plattform deutschland glaubt
überhaupt nicht deutschland glaubt an
die familie ich denke deutschland
pendelt mit dem auto zur arbeit und
fährt gerne großes auto in deutschland
ist total gerne fleisch deutschland
geändert auch nicht deutschland hat auch
bei der flüchtlinge in der
flüchtlingskrise und jetzt ganz klare
position eins doch ein anderer das was
uns medial präsentiert medial genau der
einig aber der zeitgeist also das ist
für mich tatsächlich das moderne
deutschland das sieht genauso aus und
die cdu hat genau irgendwas zu wenig
bewegt ja cdu genau mit diesen
positionen da bin ich völlig bei ihnen
und das ist so schade so schade dass wir
dieses angebot momentan nicht machen für
wirklich eine breite mehrheit in dieser
gesellschaft und wenn wir das verstanden
haben und dazu auch widerstehen und wir
können es ja anders nennen nicht
zeitgeist sondern veröffentlichte
meinung vielleicht lässt sich damit
besser aber wenn wir uns anschauen einer
hat das jetzt zumindest am anfang seines
wahlkampfs mal versucht das war markus
söder hat er sich bei dem thema
zumindest bei migration sehr klar
positioniert hatte in dem bayern
wahlkampf 2017 war es so und was ist
dann passiert am ende das nicht er ist
nicht stehen geblieben
er hat was anderes gemacht er hat sich
an die afg also dass das ist ja nicht
konservativ ist deutsche angespielt
nicht er hat glaube ich sozusagen bei
den themen eine ähnliche rhetorik
vertreten
ich gehabt also sang er kann noch in
bayern erzählen was er will wenn die
umsetzung anders aussieht glauben die
menschen irgendwann nicht mehr dies
wurde er ständig rote linie gezogen und
das die rote linie war ein flug samt und
je nachdem wie sich märkte bewegt hat
ist die rote linie mitgegangen insofern
dass die csu da nicht nicht glaubwürdig
und das andere anderen unsinn gemacht
die sache mit dem kreuz beispielsweise
wo er sich damit dem kreuz hinstellt und
sagt in jeder amtsstube ist jetzt ein
kreuz und so das war natürlich einfach
übertrieben und überzogen das war alles
nicht glaubwürdig insofern
hat er war als ein schlecht wahlergebnis
war bei rapid verantwortlich gibt es aus
ihrer sicht einen wahlkampf der
symbolisch dafür steht dass das konzept
eben aufgehen könnte da sagt sondern hat
es ja gezeigt so und das ist im prinzip
ein einziges thema gewesen wo die leute
so dankbar waren dass jemand mal
konsequent dabei geblieben ist ja meinem
thema öffentlich rechtlichen rundfunks
und das war im prinzip der
ausschlaggebende faktor in sachsen
anhalt das mal ein politiker entgegen
des windes dem entgegen schlägt steht
und sagt nein das machen wir nicht punkt
das erwarten leute und konservativ sein
dass überzeugt nach wie vor in sachsen
anhalt hat funktioniert in sachsen
funktioniert das auch das hat im übrigen
auch in baden württemberg funktioniert
nämlich mit den grünen die sind da
zutiefst konservativ und es wohl die
leute ja so wobei natürlich die fahrt
kaufen das fleisch sagt wählen dann die
grünen und ja so dass das ist der fehler
der cdu
für die umwelt mit dein ist sowie
schweren die grünen nicht so dass da wo
deine ablasshandel ich mache alles was
ich eigentlich machen dürfte und wer
dann die grünen um so ein gutes gewissen
so hat insofern ist es nicht so einfach
das alles die fleisch isst und
autofahren dass die potenziellen
cdu-wähler